please welcome assad cirquette
[Music]
thank you so much for having me this is
me jose thank you so much for having me
i am so star struck right now i'm not
kidding no you don't first of all i'm a
subscriber okay well thank you thank you
very much appreciate that i love your
talent i love watching your journey as
the editor-in-chief of el decor thank
you so
[Applause]
much i can't wait to pick your brain
will you get into some headlines with us
please okay i thought you actually have
the first one take it away all right so
first we're going to talk about
something very personal the art we hang
on the walls of our home study fines
reports a new survey found 42 percent of
people say the art in their home is
museum worthy the survey found the most
common category of art is the landscape
followed by photography and in third
place are things with sentimental value
like portraits or vintage signs and
posters so drew and ross what are your
favorite pieces of art you have hanging
at home i don't think anything i have is
museum worthy unless you can get that at
home good so i'm sorry i don't have it
um you know i like the personal stuff
you know like when when uh one of
welly's friends got us it's like at the
stop sign street intersection it says my
last name and his last name you know and
it's just right there in our kitchen
it's so beautiful because it's so
personal
yeah what about you drew i bet you have
amazing art i am a huge collector but
nothing i own is expensive um
when it comes to art i i really agree
that it just isn't the dollar amount um
it's what it means to you it's how it
speaks to you there's really
no wrong or right when it comes to art
and i think people should feel like
theirs is museum-worthy i totally agree
look
um design expert here i'm not the only
design expert up here clearly what about
you what is your personal philosophy
great to hear you both talk about
sentimentality and sentimental value
with art because the thing for me and my
apartment that i love is actually a
concert poster someone gave me from a
1982 luther vandross concert
luther vandross and cheryl lynn in
concert in los angeles and it still has
like the fraying edges and it's some
like texture and i love it and it's
bright orange and blue and so i walk
into my to my foyer at home and it's
just like the first thing i see color
and it's so great and the color is so
sunny and it's like right by my office
at home yeah if you like it i won't say
if you like it it's good but if you like
it that means it has value for you well
here's what we say
we say it's cute for you
all right well next up we got a magic
little design trick you may not have
thought of the wall street journal
reports design pro say you can jazz up
any closet with some funky wallpaper yes
just because you're out of the closet
doesn't mean you can't go back in or
spruce it up
and the bolder the better look people
are using bright and busy prints wild
patterns and taking big wrists with
color in tiny spaces okay so what do you
think about this trend that's a great
idea i wholeheartedly agree that when
you come out you should actually be
bigger and bolder more colorful than you
would before and not just closets but
also powder rooms and other small spaces
in your home it could be a pantry it
could be you know just a corner like
your entryway if you have a small
apartment and it's a way to really
experiment and have fun with color and
pattern and texture in a space where
it's low stakes and it means that you
know if it doesn't work you can just say
i don't like that low stakes smaller
spaces i decoupage
vintage maps
all over
my closet and we call it the map closet
and it's a closet that kind of houses
the majority of our stuff in the house
and it brings so much joy sounds great
it's great it's really helpful because
it's like center um well next up our
design guru our resident design expert
here at the show mikael welch
was here earlier this week i asked
mikael what for him is his favorite
trend in design right now and he said
the black accents
then we found this story and it takes it
to a whole new level apartment therapy
one of my very favorite sites reports
for just 250 000 you can get the all
black house the goth of your dreams if
you will
it's a two bedroom in lincoln illinois
all the walls are black with white trim
black flooring black in the bedrooms uh
but it also has um a lot of light the
home is built in an octagon shape
uh sun does flood in the windows to sort
of counter balance the darkness
thoughts assad i mean we knew black was
chic
this is a lot but i'm actually into it
because it's a choice right like
somebody said i'm going to go for this
and they did it and i so respect that
even if i don't want to live in that
type of environment i so respect that
yeah
you know i'm the one with white walls
and i'm actually really into this i want
to like curl up netflix for a whole day
in this house it just it looks like it's
cozy that's the word to me can you
believe i'm into it i no i cannot rossi
i'm shocked you like this house i'm
shocked i like it too when i heard about
it i was like no and then i saw the
picture i was like oh it's kind of the
opposite of what you have now right it's
like just the spiritual opposite of your
current situation so maybe that's part
of the appeal yeah and you know it's you
know we have the whole masculine thing
in common and that sort of dark brooding
bad boy thing
[Music]